hello and welcome to this video playing
I'll bow charm you will play C 3 we
already know that and you will not take
and play before I would be able two
enterprising this is the argument
against to be six move but sometimes you
can speculate that people don't plan
it's a bit it's really a bit fishy form
for black only takes the center I didn't
expect that ok let's look like French
defense here now I'm moocher h4 with
dangerous editor exchange that bloody
bishop ok c6 is a really weak spot and
seeing how to organize this position I
probably have to do the same cover cover
that's the square and then queen
descending order to to trade stuff and
now we should be five maybe maybe wants
to trade office bishop
hmm maybe I can't avoid that by going f6
ad would be extremely extremely cheeky
decision page six would be more normal I
have six looks wrong okay
hmm I stopped reading okay interesting
Jeff I was to see Ali certain that he
would trade it
couldn't take Ted 1b5 that was created
check but this way I should okay I don't
force the trade we should be for that
doesn't do much but I can now move the
night so he wants to trade down
absolutely everything i can try to win
the b5 porn I mean this is really
possible night to see 7s the same or to
a 7 ok so he's not threatening to
sacrifice that I can stop and before I
can go a 4 which is the Ted risky yeah
if it's not much
and maybe he could have no I think 97 c
8 saved it taking on a five I was trying
to say I don't play with my k form I
have to do it think anyway he has 93 and
to cover that that'd be five born I'm
playing without my king which is
normally not a good idea it's funny at
the night on a seven attacking the b5
pond which is covered by 93 so he goes
there voluntarily yeah so anything I can
do here probably not extremely dry
evolved doesn't you try to do anything i
can do i can try to enter and also go at
six I'm so move such higher because he's
got this at five idea okay so I have to
force the night back to a3 which is not
good or let's say not very helpful so f6
must be the probably the way to try
something in this position I mean if I
can like take on g 5 SS or take on e5
take here I want you five in this if I
can enter here g5 he takes here hmm and
before I probably don't have enough down
and now I cannot take on e5
time learning maybe I can still do that
here he takes f6 i'm going to take on
have form ok doesn't do it but this is
now this is now better for black for
sure absolutely for sure i get an H porn
get an H porn passer I mean it's almost
like like an ending them and ending just
with bishops
because the night the queenside is
somewhat like impasse yeah nothing
happens well okay so could have taken be
father I didn't do that okay it's tough
for him to keep it anyway so it should
fall apart check check check check check
check oh come on life forfeit on time
okay so there was a tough ending and
certainly not anything anything that
black should win it I got there slowly
somehow chance yeah I mean here you can
look at this wedding the interesting
thing is can you do something in the
ending
and yeah I tried someone I tried so one
question is is that before move any good
maybe not the engine fold it is like
that yeah it is and he always has to
take care of the b5 Hornets it's not
easy and I get this son this activated
chair and it wants to go with f5 that's
interesting and then g5 I guess yeah
probably this is Spectre I mean age 4 is
a really clear mistake I mean that
that's pretty clear and there's no need
to do it and you can go h3g 4 and so on
if you like and this is definitely not
not good and the engine this is already
giving me a window f6 and actually g51
move later but this is the key idea and
you have to have to find this here I can
interpose hear this and and here it was
what I what I saw and now I can take
before I can get this and both should
win because he has now he has for
weaknesses there four or five if you
want them that that's too much the after
g five years is falling apart I'm not
sure ever played it in the best way I
wish of h4s was pretty good but the
visually technical way should should
resign as i'm i mean i don't think i did
to it Chandu blunder anything okay damn
multiple ways now to win yep white
played this to passively this ending I
mean before something that you don't
have to play in the first place
it gives me some opportunities and I
think after hy it gots got into lost
territory and it's not a really
necessary at all you can for example on
let's say bring the King up and it's not
clear what I'm doing here I can do
things there what does the engine want
to do go to 85 somewhere oh is this I
know I think it's very difficult yet to
do something I can try but the drawer
the drawer likelihood the lag hood of
the truck was pretty high okay thanks
for watching